so
if i were to try to summarize the
wolfram physics project which
is uh you know something that's been in
your brain for a long time but really
has
just exploded in activity you know only
just months ago
yes uh so it's an evolving thing and
next week i'll try to publish this
conversation as quickly as possible
because by the time it's published
already new things will probably have
come out
so uh so if i were to summarize it
we've talked about the basics of there's
a hyper graph that represents space
there is uh transformations on that
hypergraph that represents
um times of time the progress of time
there's a causal graph there's a
characteristic of this
and the basic process of science
of yeah of science within the wolfram
physics model
is to try different rules and see which
properties of physics that we know of
known physical theories
are appear within the graphs that emerge
from that rule
that's what i thought it was going to be
oh okay
so what so what it turns out we can do a
lot better than that
it turns out that using kind of
mathematical ideas
we can say and computational ideas
we can we can make general statements
and those general statements turn out to
correspond to things that we know from
20th century physics
in other words the idea of you just try
a bunch of rules and see what they do
that's what i thought we were going to
have to do
um but in in fact we can say given
causal and variance
and computational irreducibility we can
derive
and this is where it gets really pretty
interesting we can derive special
relativity
we can derive general relativity we can
derive quantum mechanics
and that's where things really start to
get exciting
is you know it wasn't at all obvious to
me that even if we were completely
correct
and even if we had you know this is the
rule you know even if we found the rule
to be able to say yes it corresponds to
things we already know
i did not expect that to be the case and
so for somebody who is a
a simple mind and definitely not a
physicist not even close
what does derivation mean in this case
okay so so let me this is an interesting
question
okay so there's so one one thing in the
context of computational reducibility
yeah yeah right right so what you have
to do let me get let me go back to
again the mundane example of fluids and
water and things like that
right so so you have a bunch of
molecules bouncing around
you can say just as a piece of
mathematics i happened to do this from
cellular automata back in the mid 1980s
you can say just as a matter of
mathematics
you can say the continuum limit
of these little molecules bouncing
around is the navier-stokes equations
it's just a piece of mathematics it's
not it doesn't
rely on you have to make certain
assumptions
that you have to say there's enough
randomness in the way the molecules
bounce around that certain statistical
averages work et cetera et cetera et
cetera
okay it is a very similar derivation to
derive for example the einstein
equations
okay so the way that works roughly
einstein equations are about curvature
of space
uh curvature of space they talked about
sort of how you
can figure out dimension of space
there's a similar kind of way of
figuring out
if you if you just sort of say um uh you
know you're making a larger and larger
ball or larger and larger if you draw a
circle on the surface of the earth for
example
you might think the area of a circle is
pi r squared but on the surface of the
earth
because it's a sphere it's not flat the
the area of a circle isn't precisely pi
r squared as the circle gets bigger the
area is slightly smaller than you would
expect from the formula pi r squared has
a little correction term
that depends on the the ratio of the
size of the circle to the radius of the
earth
okay so it's the same basic thing allows
you to measure from one of these
hypergraphs
what is its effective curvature
and that's so um the little piece of
mathematics
that uh explains special general
relativity
is uh can map nicely to describe
fundamental property of the hyper graphs
or the curvature so
special relativity is about the
relationship of time to space
general relativity is about curvature in
in this space represented by this
hypergraph so what is the curvature of a
hypergraph
okay so first i have to explain what was
explaining is first thing you have to
have is a notion of dimension
you don't get to talk about curvature of
things if you say oh it's a curved line
but i don't know what a line is yet so
yeah what is the dimension of a
hypograph then
where from where we've talked about
effective dimension but
right that's what that's what this is
about that's what this is about is
you have your hypergraph it's got a
trillion nodes in it
what is it roughly like is it roughly
like a grid a two-dimensional
grid is it roughly like all those all
those nodes are arranged online
what's it roughly like and there's a
pretty simple mathematical way
to estimate that by just looking at the
the this thing i was describing this
sort of the size of a ball that you
construct in the hypograph
that's a you just measure that you can
just you know compute it on a computer
for a given hypergraph
and you can say oh this thing is
wiggling around but it's it's roughly
corresponds to two or something like
that or roughly corresponds to 2.6
or whatever so that's how you that's how
you have a notion of dimension
in these hypergraphs curvature is
something
a little bit beyond that it's if you
look at the how the size of this ball
increases as you increase its radius
curvature is a correction
to the size increase associated with
dimension
it's a sort of a second order term in in
the
in determining size just like the area
of a circle
is roughly pi r squared so it goes up
like r squared the two is because it's
in two dimensions
but when that circle is drawn on a big
sphere
the the actual formula is pi r squared
times one minus
uh r squared over a squared and some
coefficient
so in other words there's a correction
to and that correction term
that gives you curvature and that
correction term
is what makes this hypergraph correspond
have the potential to correspond to
curved space now the next question is
is that curvature is the way that
curvature works the way that einstein's
equations for general relativity
you know is it the way they say it
should work and the answer is
uh yes and the and so
how does that work the i mean your
the the calculation of the curvature of
this hypergraph first
for some some set of rules no it doesn't
matter what the rules are it doesn't so
long as they have causal and variance
and computational irreducibility
and and they lead to finite dimensional
space
fine non-infinite dimensional space
dimensional it can grow infinitely but
it can't be infinite dimensional
so what does a infinitely dimensional
hypograph look like
so that for example so in a tree you
start from one
root of the tree it doubles doubles
again doubles again doubles again
and that means if you ask the question
starting from a given point
how many points do you get to remember
like a circle you get to
r squared with a two there on a tree you
get to for example two to the r
it's exponential dimensional so to speak
or infinite dimensional do you have a
sense of
in the space of all possible rules how
many
uh lead to uh infinitely dimensional
hyper grass
is that no okay is that an important
thing to know
that's just an important thing to know i
would love to know the answer to that
and but but you know it gets a little
bit more complicated because for example
it's
very possibly the case that in our
physical universe that the universe
started infinite dimensional
and it only uh as it as the you know the
big bang
it was very likely infinite dimensional
and as
um as the universe sort of expanded and
cooled
its dimension gradually went down and so
one of the bizarre possibilities which
actually there are experiments you can
do to try and look at this
the universe can have dimension
fluctuations so in other words we think
we live in a three-dimensional universe
but actually
there may be places where it's actually
3.01 dimensional
or where it's you know 2.99 dimensional
and it may be that in the
in the very early universe it was
actually infinite dimensional
and it's only a late stage phenomenon
that we end up getting three-dimensional
space
but from your perspective of the
hypergraph one of the underlying
assumptions
you kind of implied but you have a sense
a hope a set of assumptions that the
the rules that underlie our universe or
the rule
that underlies our universe is static
is that the one of the assumptions
you're currently operating under
uh yes but there's a there's a footnote
to that which we should get to because
it requires a few more steps
well actually then let's backtrack to
the curvature because we're talking
about
as long as it's finite dimensional
uh finite dimensional computational
irreducibility
and causal invariance then it follows
that uh the uh that the large-scale
structure
will follow einstein's equations and now
let me
again qualify that a little bit more
there's a little bit more complexity to
it
the um uh okay so
einstein's equations in their simplest
form apply to the vacuum
no matter just the vacuum and they say
in particular what they say is if you
have um uh so
there's this term jd sick that's a term
that means shortest path
comes from measuring shortest paths on
the earth so
you look at a bunch of a bundle of gd6 a
bunch of shortest paths
it's like the pause that photons would
take between two points
then the statement of einstein's
equations is basically a statement about
a certain the that as you look at a
bundle of gd6
the structure of space has to be such
that although
the the cross-sectional area of this
bundle may
although the actual shape of the
cross-section may change the
cross-sectional area does not
that's a version that's a that's the
most simple-minded version
of army new minus a half r g mu nu
equals zero which is the
the more mathematical version of
einstein's equations it's a statement
it's a statement of thing called the
richie tensor is equal to zero
um that's that's einstein's equations
for the vacuum
okay so we get that in um as a result of
this model
but footnote big you know big footnote
because
all the matter in the universe is the
stuff we actually care about the vacuum
is
not stuff we care about so the question
is how does matter come into this
and for that you have to understand what
energy is
in these models and um one of the things
that we realized
you know last late last year
was um that there's a very simple
interpretation of energy in these models
okay and energy is basically
well intuitively it's the
amount of activity in these hyper graphs
and the way that that remains over time
so a little bit more formally you can
think about this causal graph
as having these edges that represent
causal relationships
you can think about oh boy there's one
more concept that we didn't get to this
that the notion of space like
hypersurfaces
so that this is this is a it's not as
scary as it sounds yeah
the the um it's a it's a common notion
in general activity
it's a the notion is you are you're
defining
what is a possibly what is what
um where in space-time might be
a particular moment in time so in other
words
what what is a consistent set of places
where you can say this is happening now
so to speak and you make the series of
of of sort of slices through the space
time uh through this causal graph to re
represent sort of what we consider to be
successive moments in time
okay it's somewhat arbitrary because you
can you can deform that if you're going
at a different speed and special
relativity
you tip those things if you're you can
you know there are there are different
kinds of deformations
but only certain deformations are
allowed by the structure of the causal
graph anyway
be there as it may the the the basic
point is there is a way of
figuring out you know you say what is
the energy associated with what's going
on in this
in this hypograph and the answer is
there is a precise definition of that
and it is
the formal way to say it is it's the
flux of causal edges through space like
hypersurfaces
the slightly less formal way to say it
it's basically the amount of activity
the
the see the reason it gets tricky is you
might say
it's the amount of activity per unit
volume in
in this hyper graph but you haven't
defined what volume is
so it's it's it's a little bit that you
have to buy this hypersurface gives some
more
formalism to that yeah yeah that's
because it gives a way to connect that
but intuitive we should think about is
the just the amount of activity
right so so the amount of activity that
kind of remains in one place in the
hyper graph corresponds to energy
the amount of activity that is kind of
where an activity here
affects an activity somewhere else cos
corresponds to
momentum and um and so one of the things
that's kind of cool
is that i'm trying to think about how to
say this intuitively the mathematics is
easy but the the intuitive version i'm
not sure
but basically the way that things sort
of stay in the same place and have
activity
is associated with rest mass and so one
of the things that you get to derive
is equals mc squared that is a
consequence of this
interpretation of energy in terms of
the way the causal graph works which is
kind of the whole thing is sort of a
consequence of this whole story
about updates and hyper graphs and so on
you